you know when you're dealing with a
brand new medium like the Internet
you're gonna have more freedom to do
whatever you want and get a little wild
and crazy and not have so many
oppressive notes from the from the Big
Brother upstairs that's the main
attraction and and also it's just uh I
eat I felt like they were they were a
little more forward thinking over there
the higher-ups over at Yahoo there are
some risky things about this as a series
on a network because it's two girls
driving all the action and at the heart
of the of the piece and there's just not
a lot of that in the industry it's a
male-driven industry and it's pretty
sexist and and that I think people were
a little hesitant to take a risk on on
on a woman driven peace god bless the
people at Yahoo for having some cojones
ironically cojones is where I go
straight to the mail so you know what I
mean it wasn't just the idea but it's
the it's the execution of it I mean I
saw the pilot that they made for like 50
bucks and it is you know just a little
it's a little gem it's a little
masterpiece and the thing that that is
the most appealing are just these these
two actors just relating to each other
in a really amazingly fresh way it's a
there's something very real about their
improvisational style unlike me I have
to scream all my lines these girls this
sort of like communicate so much with
just a little like offhanded of mumble
and and it was incredibly funny and and
I don't want to keep on saying the word
fresh but that damn it was French it
really was i mean we started making our
own web series just with our friend andy
and throwing them up on youtube and it
just kind of snowballed from there and
I just think it does open up tons of
opportunities for people who aren't
necessarily you know right for Network
shows or something even they kind of put
their own and you're able to show you a
real personality in your comedic
preferences yeah you also get to really
incubate ideas in ways that I don't
think and you anyone's ever been able to
do like I did a web series called drunk
history which we kind of were just doing
by ourselves for years and years and and
then we just got it now on television on
Comedy Central and they've really let us
stick to it because they're like you
guys did a thing that was successful so
keep doing it so like just being able to
put out things on on the internet and
have them have success gives you a lot
more you know freedom to define your
voice and continue making something with
your voice